hello I'm Gavin I'm Dan we're the slow
mo guys and in this video we will
attempt to destroy YouTube's ability to
correctly display it yeah we're gonna
try and annihilate the compression
algorithm we've come kind of close
unintentionally before with things like
the galleon video or other videos that
have lots of things going on at the
exact same time on the screen it usually
happens when there's tons of fine detail
all over the frame and that detail is
changing positions from frame to frame
like confetti or snow and on YouTube the
lower the resolution typically below er
the bitrate the way we're gonna try and
do is with glitter because that's got
the smallest little things the finest
little detail I'm going to try and dump
as much of it as we can in at once
onto the camera I can't think of a more
difficult test for compression than this
hopefully we make a watchable
unwatchable video yeah hopefully this is
the most watchable unwatchable video did
I just repeat exactly what you said yes
okay for these shots I want the camera
to be looking directly up at the ceiling
although on this head I can't actually
fully get vertically so I'm going to
finagle this a little bit I feel like
this tripods gonna need a chiropractor
after this I mean you might as well give
it acupuncture they're about the same
usefulness hot take me instead of sport
all right lights flooded that's a pretty
a pretty good coverage of the ceiling
all right down this is the final time
that this room and all of our equipment
will not be covered and clear I'm more
nervous than I should be let's take a
moment just to appreciate that oh look
how clean it is okay everything is not
covered in glitter I love it
this is brilliant I love it oh we go yep
it's again close yes Mike I see oh oh
all right quite full ruined it already
you may remember this device from our
oil fire video what just the old video
of it also device is a mug on a stick
Marcus made telescopic stick you ready
yeah oh goodness me it was oh you know
what I think it's so fine that it
doesn't like float about it just goes
boom like I'm pouring liquid onto it
there's an indication on how small the
little glitter pieces less than a
millimeter easily it's less than a
millimeter American Point 67.7 of a mil
all right which in American is 750 v
cinch three two one drop
oh that seemed better that seemed much
better it was much more graceful and it
didn't third on on the glass I feel like
I feel like it's it fell much slower
because it wasn't one solid mass it
managed to get some air underneath it
and spread out or float down yeah
three two one go Oh God
well it's like a cloud of fabulous like
when I walk into any room I'm most
comfortable viewing station
tsylia it's not filling the whole frame
I feel like I need to need to make the
device a bit longer that's like every
day that hurts my eyes
I like this summer in focus and summer
totally blurred I was trying to do it
focus each each
glitter if it's outfit look at that they
go it looks like a dollar I caught up
with the focus then yeah it's like
coming towards you looks like a dust
storm you know when they have like fancy
falling across the desert but red three
two one drop
dan did you by any chance write
something in the glitter can you see it
well this is some gaps yes I did write
something in the glitter I was hoping
you wouldn't see it what did you what
did you write the medical term would be
penis oh okay I could see that you'd
like smeared you can see that right
bloody honestly Velarde hard to pull
focus on it because there's no like a
unified front either there's no leading
this part job it's just a mess it's like
red blood cells this is what it looks
like to die by glitter yeah that'd be
the end of you
well that's neat you are in this video
okay we'll try a blue and I'm gonna zoom
in a lot more three two one drop three
two one drop
oh gosh I'm game
sweaty which means that the glitter is
sticking to me everywhere
oh that moment there you see that moment
maybe but it almost looks like
convergence is coming in on the center
and then when I go through it like I'm
examining yeah it looks like this is
yeah that's the glitter right there
those that all think that's really hard
I really lost because there but it looks
cool it's really it's like a like a
phone background this might be the most
abstract thing we've ever filmed is
crazy
do you like it I really like it there's
a bit of red there
the rogue piece of red spot the red yeah
that's crazy so I've put more depth in
there and it's in focus for a lot longer
this causes tiny little flares
it looks like TV static but like more
detailed good luck with this shot
compression wise I bet even if I put us
down in the lower corner that even our
faces would be just the Lockean mush
even seeing the raw edge I'm not sure if
it's coming towards us or going away
from us yeah all right I think we're
getting a hang of this now
nice zoomed in one lots of light lots of
depth I think we've done blue we have so
here's what we want all five colors you
know line all make little strips of each
one and then maybe after that because
they'll be mixed together we'll just
drop a big mixed pile sounds good
alright I'm up for that okay do you feel
like you're on Art Attack I do love that
show it's class when it three two one
drop
Wow yeah not dominated by any one
particular color it almost turned brown
though oh yeah it was as if it was
liquid because it was mixing so much
that my eyes my eyes algorithm messed up
Oh perfect bang on bang on look at
loving it
you know bigger and bigger like a green
puppy to that
reading smashing through as the golden
blue call that mixture Oh
let's burn it I don't know I smell
burning - no bloody light on fire but
melting Oh God see it smoking oh it
smells a wreck my glitter on the bulb oh
oh my goodness that's worse than I could
have thought that's like no it on there
that's caked it just don't really know
how aggressive to be with us all right
lights fixed excellent at least for the
end of this video it's giving up smoking
all right so now if you do just take all
of that that's all lovely and mixed and
we'll just drop a plate of that okay one
times plates for a grand finale
you're gonna do a bit glitter Bay oh
yeah sure oh look at that I estimate
three months before I get all this
glitter off I'll be finding glitter in
the shower for months not as much bad
luck as breaking a mirror but it's up
there it's worse than breaking the
mirror because breaking a mirror does
actually do nothing well coming from the
guy with like 48 years of bad luck that
look alright you don't need to be
suspicious to realize you've got glitter
in your ear from four months ago it just
happens
suspicious drop alright so this one
might be the most mental one all the
colors mixed together attempting a focus
pull
oh goodness me that's the big thing
oh nice the Big Bang
what uh it looks like extreme Christmas
so look at that front coming through
just briefly
you know how TV displays colors yeah
this is gonna be hard for a screen to
display each frame is different colors
everywhere bits everywhere
we should export each into individual
frame and just sell each one as a
painting wait do you have 3790 4 or 3
rows
[Music]
why is it bleeding
oh look at the different layers I think
if we film this in 3d somehow my head
would split open explain a bit where
they're coming through all the
flickering mush and like coming in you
can see that little granules I want to
get a shot that's pretty much all that
so I'm going to set the focus to a
minimum which is well like just under
two feet away so still they'll still go
out of focus but we should see all that
flickering mess with the little granules
coming through at the front 3 2 1
you see see all the little specks inside
each yeah see the iris shape there
that's because that's the stuff that's
already landed oh my god it's an amazing
effect and that cool you know it looks
like it's when they have those pictures
in the quiz shows where it's like what
is this and then I get it slowly pieces
together yeah I love the different
stages of that one that was my favorite
one I think interestingly on this one we
left the garage door open and you can
actually see
the wind is actually like subtly
affecting it looks a bit stormy it's
really Swiss this is like a maelstrom of
glitter yeah like a few flows and
rotations that we weren't getting a
little there are honestly so many
variations that we could have tried
every single time you do this with even
the slightest change is completely
different well on the lens alone I can
make it look completely different
everything one of these is different let
alone the color of the glitter the size
the glitter yeah
how much is dropped how far is dropped
stupid thing hey so do you think we've
managed to defeat YouTube compression oh
I don't know but I feel like we defeated
my eyes I think defeat my head at the
feet of the monitor and even just
looking at the raw I've never seen such
lossless video like that just all crit
I'm expecting compression and I'm not
saying it's so weird just going like
cross-eyed and less shutting my eyes and
seeing the exact same thing you don't
know where to look
yeah yeah I truly believe that sadly
only you and I have truly been up to see
what that video actually looks like what
because you wouldn't be able to show it
and compressed though how would you show
people I'd have to put it into a
uncompressed QuickTime or a stream of
tips and shove it on a SSD and just give
it to you and your hands how many
subscribers do too many although we have
been thrown around the idea of making a
best of slow mo guys 4k blu-ray so if
that does happen that would be the most
lossless format we've ever presented any
footage and I'll definitely stick that
video on there so you'd be more likely
to see closer to what we're seeing in
this video but you could probably get
the difference up yeah yeah okay you
could because you couldn't do that on
YouTube because it would just be like
they're the same yeah we'll do like one
of those adverts like oh it's the slow
mo guys blu-ray hears 1080p well
hopefully you enjoyed that video you
probably didn't actually even though you
got a headache like me but we made it
anyway just to try and break the system
thank you very much for watching
make sure you subscribe to the slow mo
guys and we have a second channel to
easier to watch videos on that one yeah
you've got some glitter on here you've
got some just in my eyebrow in within
the hair you know okay should we clear
up mm I have to did tomorrow yeah